l'équipe de la maison france 5 se met en
place après le loir et cher stéphane
thébaut s'intéresse à des créateurs
orléanais le magazine de décoration de
90 minutes réalisée en seulement deux
jours et demi
tout est préparé à l'avance sauf la
rencontre avec l'artiste
- j'en sais avant d'arriver sur place
c'est pas que mieux je me porte
c'est que plus un modèle et je vais
mettre à la place du téléspectateur et
poser des questions à la personne que
j'ai rencontrée qu'aimerait poser les
téléspectateurs donc bien sûr on est on
est rodé ça fait dix neuf ans qu'on fait
l'émission on a toute une équipe
d'enquêteurs donc les tristes qui
travaillent avec nous la rédactrice en
chef
le producteur toute l'équipe technique
qui est déjà en train de se mettre en
place qui fait que j'ai pas besoin de
leur dire où il faut qu'ils se mettent
le savent déjà
fort heureusement ça nous fait gagner du
temps mais voilà tous ces éléments font
que lorsque j'arrive moi je suis
quasiment dans un fauteuil
j'ai juste à converser et être curieux
du travail qu'effectue la personne en
face de moi un chef opérateur de
caméraman un ingénieur du son deux
assistants l'atelier du designer benoît
vieux blade et pour quelques heures sous
les feux des projecteurs
une agitation à laquelle il réagit de
façon assez stoïque
c'est un honneur d'en recevoir la maison
france 5 et d'être surtout mis à
l'honneur pour cette occasion mais on
est toujours un petit peu ému quoi de se
placer devant les caméras puis surtout
le ce qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important pour nous c'est de faire
connaître notre travail et notre travail
quand il est connu du véhicule et il est
bien vivant que c'est un souhait le plus
cher en tant que créateur souhaite c'est
d'avoir un public est là c'est le cas
quand une émission de télé qui passe sur
tous est une émission de cette ampleur
là très rythmé le tournage de la maison
france 5 se poursuivra dans l'après midi
chez une autre artiste l'émission elle
sera diffusée le vendredi 28 février à
20h50 sur france 5
[Musique]